the cmt music awards e.t was the only
show backstage with country's finest
starting with a high flying first for
carrie underwood
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christine you do the aerial work i was
like carrie is going full-on pink for me
right now i was like i wonder if i could
do that and i have the song ghost story
and i feel like well if there's a song
to try it on it's this one this might be
a new workout for carrie underwood i
think so mike fisher what did you make
of carrie underwood's performance i was
a little bit nervous i watched some of
the uh when she first started to do it
but
i mean that was crazy
harry whose sword in a high-flying
spectacle pre-taped at her vegas
residency kept our cmt winning streak
going with the help from jason aldean
jason aldean and
jason aldean and carrie underwood if i
didn't love you
that brings kerry's total cmt wins to 25
jason's won four picking up two last
night and marking a milestone jason
aldean how was this your first video of
the year winning 17 years 17 years in
the game it feels good your 26 number
one of them i get both of them oh that's
right i did you're right
i got two collaborative and video of the
year where are these bad boys going in
the house um i have a little trophy case
in the house oh and that's faith hill
gorgeous in green squeezing by our
exclusive spot backstage and sending
jason up
[Music]
jason performed a memorable country
crossover with brian adams outside in
the rain definitely wet but it was it
was fun getting to perform with brian is
always fun it's one of my guys that i
grew up watching and so always fun to
perform with him he's great when they
weren't performing and winning jason
with white britney and kerry with mike
made it a double date night yep the
couples were everywhere
[Music]
a little date night for mom and dad
tonight
girl dad to two co-hosts kane brown
posed with wife caitlin three months
after giving birth to daughter cody and
keeping the pregnancy hush-hush why did
you up to go that route and keep it a
secret um i just wanted the privacy you
know social media can be a little harsh
i loved every second of it i would do it
again let's do this you ready i'm ready
all right kane stepped in for kelsey
ballerini who emceed from home with
covet howdy prep me and anthony went
golfing yesterday to get a little more
chemistry together
what yeah becoming best friends now at
least i think we are are you ready
nashville winner winner chicken dinner
yeah that was the first thing that
happened when i walked the door that's
not a bad way to start a red carpet cody
johnson ladies and gentlemen
cmt awards newbie cody johnson got a
kiss from wife brandi the double winner
beat out thomas rhett for mail video of
the year but he and wife lauren still
have four reasons to celebrate at home
our two-year-old she walked into my
bathroom and she goes it's mommy
and she kept like asking herself and i
was like oh this is embarrassing i just
i guess i never fixed myself up miranda
lambert
miranda's husband brady mclaughlin got a
sweet kiss while jesse james decker gave
her man eric this
new tattoo oh my gosh j
j d she put her i got his ring so i
talked to him
[Music]
performer miron morris got very real
about her and hubby ryan heard's nearly
seven years together we have our moments
for sure that aren't like rainbows and
sunshine but we just laugh our way
through it because we know that like
we're gonna be in this until the end and
we better get it together
keith urban left early he lives 20 miles
away so he could have raced home to wife
nicole and their girls and cole swindell
wasn't going to let the rain ruin his
performance with laney wilson
[Music]
literally 30 seconds before we went live
she's like are we going out in the rain
and she said let's i said oh yeah we're
going out if they're standing in the
rain we're going in the rain
now to a mother-daughter date the judds
delivered their first award show
performance in nearly 22 years
[Music]
why did it take so long to get you back
here at an award show and perform
nashville ran out of rhinestones
that damn dolly parton took all of them
love building a bridge ladies don't you
think it's time
the epic performance complete with
gospel singers is perhaps a preview of
what to expect september 30th when they
hit the road for their swan song tour
called the final tour
are you ready to be sharing a tour of us
together i turn my carport into a little
manufacturing factory to make judge
t-shirts the one that i made says the
judge's final
tour and underneath it says we you not
there you have it
[Music]
another powerful performance jimmy allen
monica in little big town who took the
cmts to church with their collaboration
pray it's amazing to be able to sing it
on this platform if you do don't believe
we pray i feel like prayer is really
therapy i'm still processing you know my
father's loss he was the one person i
could always call to like center me
kenny chesney closed the show with this
party anthem beer in mexico
maddie font was ready to party after
maddie and tay's woman you got won group
duo video of the year
i've been drinking wine god knows me
maddie delivered a wild speech which
included crying cussing and cracking a
joke about will smith at your highest
moment be careful that's when the devil
comes for you let me tell y'all
something about the devil he's trying to
get you when you're doing right
but god loves you
maddie's other musical half tay dai
appeared from home with her
three-month-old daughter leighton that
little fighter recently spent 53 days in
the nicu
she's great she's in mom modes the baby
is good and so strong like her mama
with black pumas brought the house down
and who does she have to thank for the
collab her husband like he knows all the
words to y'all songs he was always
playing in the house and i love them and
i think we've just had a mutual
affinity for one another mickey and the
guys are about to shoot a cmt crossroads
special but before that she's taken part
in leann rimes's episode which premieres
thursday e.t was exclusive on set for
the first all-female edition
honey this is a big big night for you
liam it is it's hard to take in
i was just thinking i've hit the
milestone of 25 years before i'm 40.
i can't wrap my mind around it i grew up
listening to leanne and wanting to do
what she was doing
at 13. now to get to collaborate like
this is
wild
brandi clark joins leanne for a song she
wrote for eddie on their wedding day
almost 11 years ago the track will be on
her new album god's work out september
16th and hopefully performed on tour
starting may 13. how
[Music]
when you're not just singing with her in
the car right it's like whew she makes
this stuff
sound real easy and it's not
that is the ultimate girl group right
there it is going to be a spectacular
special